thank you everybody for joining the talk
today can everybody hear me okay Mike's
working yeah okay if you'd like to
follow along there's QR code there which
will take you to the to the recall
quickly a little bit about myself uh
hero Bronte I'm a senior principal data
scientist at cbsl
um some of the other stuff was mentioned
earlier so we can keep it moving
I'd like to hear a little bit about you
though who in this room by show of hands
with data
a pretty broad question who runs queries
okay so we lost a few but still the
majority of you who Engineers features
all right who trains ml models
all right so it's dying down a little
bit deploys models to production
all right even fewer who here has felt
the pain with all of these things
right all of us
so a disclaimer about this talk I'm not
going to be going into any bleeding edge
deep learning Frameworks we won't be
talking quasim we won't be talking
blockchain we won't be talking Computing
on the edge however we will be talking
about something that I think is pretty
near and dear to all of our Arts uh
saving a whole lot of time when we have
to go through that cumbersome and
tedious process of data collection and
feature engineering
so if we can do this exercise together
everybody uh close your eyes Okay close
your eyes and imagine that you are a new
employee
and your boss approaches you with your
first project
and here she says okay I need this I
need you to build this churn model for
me okay and I need it by tomorrow uh-oh
right you're this brand new employee you
know absolutely nothing about the data
landscape database is over here Cloud
Warehouse over there distributed file
system over here what are you to do
this can be characterized as a cold
start problem show of hands has anybody
familiar with this term uh cold start
problem with like Rec systems okay a few
so the cold start problem emerges when
we need to have a Rec system needs to
have a perspective on what to recommend
it to but it doesn't know anything about
you because you're brand new it doesn't
know all of your you know tastes and
preferences from a long history and so
this is kind of a cold start problem for
the data scientists because they don't
know the data so how are they to start
modeling if they don't know the data
Pop Quiz what should you do
a hunker down it's going to be a long
night
B fake it till you make it
C make a scene and rage quit
or D up
to each their own
but the correct answer is the other
and my tip to all of you especially
managers or anybody thinking about data
infrastructure is to not put your
colleagues in this position in the first
place
and how can we do that
good question okay I know it's a little
hand wavy to say we can make things
better but let's unpack that a little
bit let's talk about it
here we have a spectrum and on the on
your left hand side it's starting from
scratch right Pure Play cold start
problem and on the opposite end of the
spectrum we have a full-fledged feature
store I have all the magical features
that are very informative and they're at
my fingertips I can get them in
milliseconds
a perfect world
but we know as technologists as
developers that there are trade-offs and
to achieve that low low latency it's
going to come at a cost you have to pay
the piper at some point
that cost can be you know what you're
actually paying for that expensive
caching or it can also be the the debt
costs that come with developing a
feature score so let's try to move
somewhere up the Spectrum but you know
without going to the to the total right
so we have some queries under Version
Control that's good that's a start right
I can take those queries at a different
disparate repos and I can start running
them
not great because I need to do a little
hunting and packing
um it still assumes that I'm going to
submit those queries the old-fashioned
way uh one after another serially but we
can do better right and that's where
cold start lives cold start lives in
that space where there is a collection
of curated queries and it's doing some
magical things behind the scenes to
ensure that when you are running those
queries
you're getting your data back as soon as
possible and it is primed for modeling
foreign
is really built around this powerful
classical feature Factory
and if you're used if you're starting to
use uh cold start you you want to know
what queries are in my query Bank right
um it has some convenience methods that
allow you to list dialects which which
databases are supported bigquery
redshift postgres whatever it is then
any one of those dialects will have
entities associated with them so coming
from the healthcare domain and entity in
our world might be like a provider id
for a doctor or a member ID for a member
or a prospect ID for somebody who's not
quite yet not a member by death those
are some examples of entities an entity
may have one or many domains associated
with it so we think about a member
entity maybe we're interested in their
historical medical utilization as a
domain or perhaps
social determinants of Health for
example or benefit utilization those are
just examples and then a domain may have
one or many queries associated with it
so by establishing this relationship
I can go mine as a new user and say
I'm going to be working I'd like to know
which queries are available okay I see
that the bigquery has some queries with
it and it has these 10 domains
associated with it I don't necessarily
have to know every single query or every
line of code
um that that provides those queries but
I can see from a 30 000 input view okay
thematically these are the 10 chunks or
domains or categories of features that
I'll be pulling into my model
uh we'll look at some examples later of
how we do this but uh suffice it to say
that
in order to achieve this we have to
enforce some opinionated patterns about
how the queries are written are written
so that they can be dynamically
templated at runtime those queries are
then uh concurrently executed
there are mechanisms in place to ensure
row level consistency and we can create
composite keys on the Fly for you
and also because this uh this is a
package for data scientists it's
primarily
has anybody in here ever
um leaked data into a model right it's
it's The Accidental thing where you know
you're going to make a prediction and
you are the model is seeing some data
that would not or your training uh model
and uh you're feeding in data that would
not have been observable at the point in
time when you would like to make that
prediction so cold start helps kind of
prevent this problem it's also memory
friendly it does some things like
intelligent downcasting if you instruct
it to and you can even return out of
core data structures when you're ready
to go to production
it will freeze these queries so that
you're running the same
query template
um dynamically which will dynamically
get templated at runtime when you're
ready to go to prod and it's also
customizable in that you can uh I think
you can set an instruction to create
mini batches or even you know retry
so we kind of talk through this flow a
little bit but if you start feature
Factory it stages the electrons table
everything after start feature Factory
by the way is happening behind the
scenes for you okay
so you see the leftmost table it then
parsens and collects queries
I will then freeze those queries for a
production run if you instruct it too it
templates the queries it runs them
concurrently it collects some metadata
about all those all those results that
it just created because it needs that
metadata to then dynamically build this
big left merge or left joint query right
so if I had 20 queries that had 100
features each getting returned it needs
to dynamically build that query so that
it can enter on that last query so you
can get back to a nice slide data frame
then it will drop the intermediate
tables do some cleanup for you and
ultimately return your data frame that
is ready to go right into a scikit
pipeline or whatever the ml Library du
jour is
let's do questions at the end please
so this is what an example query might
look like first off we have to name it
the tip here is to name the query in a
way that uh is somewhat indicative of
what it is and that helps later on
because when uh when the result returns
it actually prepends the query name to
the feature name so that you can
maintain some semblance of data lineage
because maybe you need to get back a
data frame with you know 5000 features
in it you might want to know where
exactly it came from so that allows you
to make the association back to the
query
the queries need to be tagged these
three tags are really important the
dialect The Entity and the domain and
you tag it just like you would add in a
note or comment rather in one of your
queries
then you'll notice over here this
leftmost query in the first CTV that's
really important that's where your stage
table gets dynamically templated at
runtime and then it subsequently
constrains any uh any later CTE
uh then in the where Clause there's a
midi and a back state that gets applied
in the staging table it has the Min and
back state that either you are set that
you're specifying so that you would any
other tables that are part of that query
that need to be date constrained you
would then reference the midday back
state and lastly if you look at the
outermost query there uh you'll notice
that we're grouping by this this idx
that's the composite key that I
referenced before which is essentially a
concatenation of your entity ID the
Mandate and a Mac state
so
this does a lot of stuff for you there
are a lot of benefits and a lot of time
being saved so far but it's not you
still need to to give it the instruction
what are you trying to model what are
you trying to do but it doesn't ask that
much of you all at once is for you to
define a table that has your entity ID
and your dependent variable call it why
you also have the option for example if
you're
you know working with Journal data where
you have the same member ID that is
showing up multiple observations are
just different time periods you can add
in the Min and the max date
so that you know you're you're you have
multiple observations for a given end to
the IP that is also acceptable
so that's pretty much it
um that's not a whole lot to ask an end
user
so
um all that's good all that's well but
now it's time to actually see it in
action I would like to convince each one
of you
that this is really really easy to use
and it's a great intermediate solution
to this cold start problem
so let me cut over to
a notebook
and by the way this quick start notebook
can be found in
in the repo for those of you that use
the QR code before if you just want to
jump into examples you can you can find
it right there
all right so this is just a little bit
of a reiteration of what we said before
I'm going to go ahead and hit install
hold start here
a little bit bigger
all right
cool and now we'll just restart our
kernel
we'll do some obligatory Imports
okay
all pretty good so far all right now
this is the the first piece that I
mentioned we're going to inspect the
query bank right now I have some test
queries in there and the only dialect
that is applicable right now is bigquery
so now I know okay in the query bank I
have some queries presumably a problem
from this Warehouse or from this
database all right let's then take
bigquery and pass it into list entities
now I need to know what entities do I
have queries associated with
all right so I see we have a team ID and
a game ID I used
um a public data set in bigquery for
NCAA basketball
um so that's why we we have those
entities
now I'm going to pass the dialect and
the team ID that I'm interested in or
the team ID rather into this list
domains
okay we get back we get back a couple
domains so we have a domain for mascot
for wins for losses for venue for
taxonomy
and then lastly
we can also see which individual queries
are available right now there's there's
just five in there that you can have at
uh at CVS Health we have I think close
to 40 different queries in The Brood
bank that we're using that ultimately
return you know thousands of features
um
so we typically wouldn't need to use
that list queries method unless you had
already gone through this exercise and
you realize oh I first explored these
domains with these queries but they
weren't terribly informative or maybe
they're not applicable for the type of
modeling problem that I'm trying to
solve so you can zero in on specific
queries as well
all right so now we're just going to go
ahead and Define our leftmost table and
in this case what we're doing is
um basically saying you know did this
team in the 2016 Year have a winning or
losing season was there was there win
percentage greater than or less than 50
percent and we're going to use the the
prior five years to see if we can
predict that based on some of these test
queries that we have so I'm going to go
ahead and run this run this we'll look
at our class and balance in just a
moment here
okay so we have a pretty nice you know
it never looks that good in uh in our
world it's so it's like a crazy
imbalance but but that's pretty pretty
good okay so now we need to uh we're
gonna start using feature Factory and
all it wants from you is some
instructions about which dialect do I
need to use and some other uh you know
arguments depending on because this is
actually using SQL Alchemy to start an
engine behind the scenes and different
different dialects have different inputs
that are necessary to build that
connection string and this is a really
flexible dictionary so like if you're
using you know another another database
or something that requires additional
arguments it's extensible that way
so I'm going to go ahead and run it and
it's going to start the engine the
engine has been started
and we're just calling help there on on
the feature Factory class but we can go
ahead and run it
all right so that now this is where the
pump starts
all we've done is defined our leftmost
table that same table that I just showed
you before and we're specifying where we
want all these results to go and they
don't have to go anywhere you could just
return a data frame and uh you know work
with it but let's say for
um you know memorialization purposes or
you know we want to version all the
training data sets that we're working
with you write it out to a Target table
so note that most of these are defaults
and if we look at for example the uh the
readme
most most of the time all you need to do
is pass in these five arguments
right leftmost stable feature cable fbid
domains but here you know I'm just
showing you the others so it's it's
clear what else you can do with uh with
feature Factory but I'm going to go
ahead and run that and so what it's
doing right now is staging that leftmost
cable then it's going to template and
execute those queries concurrently
all right so we ran all five queries
they were all successful one of them
happened to fail it would have let me
know okay and it would have kept going
uh you could make it so that if any one
query fails it just you know throws its
arms up in here in itself
so we finished we ran all five queries
and now we are
interested in doing some modeling right
so we can call this get data frame
method on feature Factory which will
return feature CF for us
and then we're just going to move
that idx column to our index and now we
have a nice clean data set right we have
a clean data set with all of these
wonderful features
and this is ready to go for modeling all
I need to do from from there I can also
check out the uh
the table Name by the way
um
now just to confirm that the
that cold start wrote These features out
to the feature table we could go ahead
and query it so we're passing in the
table name that was just returned from
it into this query okay so great it did
what it was supposed to do it gave us
back our data frame and it also
preserved these features uh in that in
that table
so Chopin's who in the room has worked
with um muscular and Pipelines
they're great right and uh and column
Transformers were were a game changer uh
and you can do things like you know
create your numeric Transformer your
categorical Transformer and then push
them into uh one Pipeline and you can do
things like you know d-type include
number or d-type include categorical
data type
so that now I have a pretty smart
pipeline in just a couple lines of code
I would consider this like the most
basic of basic pipelines but it's
extremely generalizable this is the kind
of code I would want somebody who's
brand new building their first model to
start using and then build upon right
they can add in all sorts of different
steps and feature Transformations within
their pipeline
but
remember our features PF all we're doing
is saying hey that First Column that's
your why everything else have fun x
so we have created our pipeline we fit
it and now we have this helper function
here to evaluate how the model did
I didn't say it was going to be a good
model okay because this is NCAA win
percentages we know that there is all
sorts of magic that happens and uh in
the tournament
um but hopefully the point that comes
across is that wasn't very hard
essentially all I had to do was specify
a couple tables a date range call this
feature Factory thing and then I'm ready
to go
and my pipeline my code doesn't have to
change that much I can still be using a
tensorflow pipeline I can still be using
a scikit cut whatever it is
just the way that we're going about
getting these features is now condensed
and we're doing a lot more work in a
shorter period of time
so
in conclusion
cold start
dramatically accelerates the modeling
process your your time to value your
productivity especially for new folks I
had this idea in my head that that this
Library would be really useful
especially for new employees but then
what I found out in talking to
colleagues was that they started using
it for General exploratory data analysis
and because you know having this this
wide data frame of data can be useful in
other contexts as well
it encourages collaboration and
peer-reviewed reusable queries that one
is super important
um what a shame it would be if all of us
rewrote the same query or rewrote the
same code 20 times over and we didn't
stand to benefit from peer reviewing
one version and making that one version
really great while the rest of us worked
on creating additional queries that were
then subsequently peer reviewed
this Library emphasizes approachability
and usability want to make it really
easy
um you know chopins who believes this is
something that would be relatively
trivial to incorporate into your daily
workflow pip install and then
instantiate feature Factory
anyone okay a couple of you so maybe I
haven't committed to everyone and if you
if you need additional convincing I
would say pip install it and check out
the quick story
uh cold sort also abstracts away
efficient design patterns you know using
CTE is avoiding avoiding data leakage
Etc and it's extensible in that you can
support additional dialects add
additional queries so if these are some
of the types of things that you're
interested in then cold start might be
might be good for you
so where are we going from here
um a couple couple things is pretty hot
off the prices added to 5pi about two
days ago we want to add a switch for
instead of writing to intermediate
tables that then get dropped
um you know just write parquet files out
to out to your bucket
um so that might be another option the
option to return different types of data
frames maybe like a folders data frame
or something like that some of us may
have the 10 controllers talk yesterday
um testing for more databases and adding
um uh some retrying decorators from
tenacity to some of the queries to make
them even more durable maybe you retry
you know three or four times or stop
after 60 seconds or whatever it is
so that's it I want to thank you for uh
[Applause]
appreciate it and now I'd like to take
any questions that you may have
I believe
yeah actually I'll ask a different one
because you did answer the one that I
had to refer to the end
um so when you do this kind of joint
path style feature engineering um often
you don't have a one-to-one relationship
and that's why you have these left
joints um
but then you need some kind of
aggregation
um I mean I couldn't quite figure out in
the talk who picks what to Aggregate and
how to aggregate I mean uh is it somehow
magically in the library that you do the
specified
so if we look at this example here the
outermost query will always provide the
index
and the final join
um you know joins on that index it's an
inner join to all of these future tables
so you are guaranteed that the table
that comes out with the final of the
final big live table with all of your
queries it's guaranteed to have the same
number of observations
as the input table that you specified so
long as this pattern
is being observed
I guess maybe if you simplify the
question who writes that query on the
right
the individuals that are contributing to
the library so say you know this domain
ABC particularly well maybe you add
those queries to the query Bank maybe
your colleague knows another
complementary domain and he or she adds
those okay
yes
come back to the slide with the Emojis
on it that one okay so when you say me
I'm late receiving you uh
have a little bit more color of what
that means yeah it is a little bit
reductive but essentially we are it's
it's happening at runtime
right so with a feature store you know
part of the premium that you're paying
is for you're specifying a schedule on
these queries to refresh every 10
seconds or every minute or something and
then you're having to pay for this like
really you know fast cash right so that
those those queries are ready to go when
you need them
um you know cold start things are
happening at runtime albeit in as
parallelizable of a way as possible
assuming the query already made its
initial line
no that they actually executed runtime
so when we I'm just thinking of thinking
about like you know
chart where you mentioned merging that's
typically depending on how large the
query can be computationally expensive
and cause slowly agency so that's that's
kind of what's motivating your question
putting a higher point
so yeah I'm using I'm using latency kind
of generally there right I'm just saying
like essentially at a time that it'll
take you to have features ready to be
long I'm considering that latency in
this kind of reductive context
um but yes those queries are are run at
runtime and let's say you have you know
15 queries that you're submitting one
takes one minute and another one takes
two minutes uh that's the longest
running query you're going to have to
wait at least two minutes right for
those for those features or for those
feature queries to finish on it
potato potato
um
yeah I I kind of called it time to
Features here but essentially it's just
I'm a data scientists I really want to
start modeling right now how much how
long do I have to wait until I can start
doing that will I have a long last
question
yeah I wouldn't you know try to protect
I wouldn't try to like shove it through
shove a circle the circular Peg through
a square hole on this one it's really
assuming that you have like the database
or a warehouse out there and you you're
extracting features from it
um and you just want to kind of build up
this this library of queries uh
following this pattern so that you can
stand to benefit from
accelerated model development but not
yeah that's that's kind of out of scope
for this particular project
uh so latency is like duration or time
so low latency means it's happening fast
and highly easy to take a long time
am I right
I think there's another question over
here thanks
for help your job I have one question
please talk about the uh
so let's say we have a very big data set
and it's like running into terabytes or
some few labels which are very fact
takers so is it possible to have that
some data in your view and then we can
refer them
you could Target a view of materialized
view a table in in the queries it
doesn't it doesn't actually care what
that is if it were materialized you it
would just go that much faster
um
but uh yeah it's not picking about how
that that is actually in your in your
database
I think there's another question right
behind
yes where is the query bank and where do
I put both queries and
is there ever a situation where I say
one team and two companies we put all
our queries in this one bucket and
another team puts them all on Dropbox
you need to get everybody together to
put in one on Olympic system you can I I
wanted to create a little bit of
flexibility here so the query Bank by
default lives within the cold start
directory so like if you went ahead and
you
just all the package you could add them
in there I know sometimes it's kind of
hard to like find that but that's also
why
we have a um
just jump to the right thing here there
is
a parameter for the query directory so
let's say it's in your home directory or
it's some other repo that somebody has
to clone and it's just a collection of
these you can point to it so that much
is portable
but um you know you can certainly add
them to the to the default location if
you're interested in doing so
yes so um you're kind of piggybacking
off that question I guess the right way
for an organization to adopt this would
be to Fork this library and then develop
our own proprietary to regain and good
version control us like basically the
same way any other software to use
Version Control I think so that's kind
of that's the way that we've been doing
it internally at CVS Health
um just because I like having the things
close together right but it doesn't
force you to do that you can certainly
you know have an adjacent repo or you
know maybe
um like a shared drive or something
where everybody adds their their queries
that much as flexible but yeah I think
the pattern that you outline with
forking and then adding your your uh
queries to the Quarry Bank directly is
probably the easiest or lowest overhead
pattern so like sorry follow-up question
for that so
um if we did that then we wouldn't have
to like adhere to the I mean it seems
like a lot of this is based off of cbs's
like internal design patterns in the
theory guys it's database essentially no
that that much has been abstracted away
this is completely agnostic to anything
at my company or your company
um you know you can Target any database
or Warehouse that SQL Alchemy is capable
of connecting to and you can drop in any
queries that are associated with your
target
all right well just want to thank
everybody again uh for the opportunity
if you're interested in cloning the repo
check it out or just hit install it if
you're interested in uh career
opportunities at CBS Health we're hiring
quite a bit so please check out our
careers page thank you all so much
[Applause]